how much faster is the m2 macbook air if
you upgraded slow ssds and you give it a
decent amount of ram well today we will
find out because i have two identical
models in front of me both of these have
eight core graphics which means it's
going to be a perfectly fair test
whereas some people have put out some
benchmarks where you're looking at a 16
gig 512 but it also has the upgraded gpu
which we're now seeing could slow down
in certain cases in some cases could be
faster this is going to be perfectly
fair we're not only going to run some
benchmarks we're also going to run real
world tests for productivity as well as
multitasking and see how much does the
base one slow down and how much
performance you gain with the extra ram
and at this point even mkbhd
is saying that the base model should not
exist so if you're on a budget and you
might want to buy one you're already
stretching your money really thin
let's see what actually happens right
out of the gate we have to start out
with a black magic ssd speed test we
know that the base model has that one
nan chip instead of two like apple used
before and as you guys can see it's
making a significant difference not only
that but the write speed on this m2 is
also faster than i expected i usually
let this run until it settles in and
gives consistent scores and now we could
see that the base model 256 gets
1321 right compared to
2769 right on the 512 model that is more
than twice as fast for the write speed
and the read speed which is more
important we have a thousand four
hundred and forty five for the read on
the base and two thousand hundred thirty
five on the five twelve that is also
slightly more than twice as fast and
that's gonna be important for ram swap
when the system needs extra ram it
writes to the ssd and then reads from it
and it can definitely impact performance
which we'll take a look at now along
with that slower ssds can impact
transfer speeds and way more than you
would imagine this is our sabrand 4
terabyte thunderbolt 3 external ssd it
is nice and quick not nearly as fast as
the 512 model m2 ssd so the limitation
will be the drive but let's go ahead and
see how long it takes to transfer our
regular pc test folder all right guys
the differences are drastic
our 512 model took 57 seconds to
transfer this folder and go ahead and
take a guess down below how long it took
the 256 gig model to transfer i don't
think you guys will believe it
that took
six minutes and 30 seconds
yes that is literally more than six
times longer now if you look at the
black magic this speed test you would
think okay it will be twice as long this
is these are twice as fast on the 512
but no the difference comes in that with
the total capacity and how much of the
fast right portion you have with most
modern ssds they won't write that full
speed the whole time they will slow down
and the 256 gig model will slow down to
around 200 megabytes a second once the
fast portion is written where the 512 it
will write faster and it has a lot more
of that fast section it can write to so
here's the differences they are insane
and now we're going to start our
productivity tasks but before that i
want to let you know that we are giving
away a brand new m2 macbook air and i
don't care where you are in the world i
will pay for the shipping and i will pay
for any taxes or fees that are due all
you have to do is one be subscribed to
max tech and two comment below on our
launch week videos that is from last
friday up until sunday july 24th you can
comment once per video that increases
your chances and on july 25th we will be
announcing the winner in a video that
will be posted we're gonna do it
randomly so please don't fall for any of
the scammers down in the comments
section report those guys and wait for
that video and make sure to comment now
starting out here i want to show you
guys the activity monitor because on
these fresh systems that very little
background tasks we just have a couple
monitoring apps and then we have
creative cloud open our 8 gig already
has
145 megabytes in the swap meaning it is
using the ssd as ram whereas a 16 gig it
is using more it's using 9.3 gigs it's
caching stuff but we have no swap used
now most people will have background
applications open maybe slack teams they
might have spotify open they will have
some web browsing tabs open so when some
people go and run benchmarks if nothing
else opened well it's not completely
fair especially if they're talking about
this ssd issue so if you're trying to be
very lightweight on the ram i am using
safari for that purpose and we're only
going to open up five tabs let's play
mkbhd's excellent review where he does
mention some of the issues we'll open up
ign over here a lot of these media sites
have a lot of photos they have ads that
refresh in the background so far for
this kind of load i mean even the base
model is super responsive here and it
looks like even for just five web
browsing tabs we're running 562
megabytes of swap compared to zero and
now i'm going to run a render in the
latest version of blender which supports
gpu
rendering now the app itself isn't going
to take up a ton of ram and this scene
does have a lot of detail but
we do need ram for the graphics to work
because it is shared remember both these
have acor graphics so it's completely
fair the graphics are maxed out and
blender is using just over three gigs of
ram and on our base model we're using
1.3 gigs or so of swap so it is adding
on to having those web browsing tabs
open but even if we didn't have that
open it we will still be using swap so
that part doesn't matter much whereas on
the 16 gigs we are not using any swap at
all all right the test is finished and
the 16 gig model took four minutes and
59 seconds
one second longer than the 8 gig model
so it shows that there we are not seeing
any difference at all and the 8 gig
performed really well and now i'm
running a different project file that
was sent to us to test out blender
performance for projects that use a lot
of memory a lot of them don't but some
specific workflows do
and here even a 16 gig model is using
swap but of course the 8 gig model has
to use a lot more and we're seeing some
big slow downs wow that's a big
difference 6.6 seconds compared to 37.2
seconds now when you're running this
calculation it requires just over six
gigs of memory and you guys see what
that does to the base model now i think
most projects don't require this and if
you're somebody that does work with
projects that need a lot of memory
you're probably going to go with for a
14 or a 16 inch and now what about for
photo editors i have adobe lightroom
classic opened up right here and let's
go ahead and just jump through some of
these images
and right away
you guys are seeing
that the 16 gig model with 512
is noticeably snappier now we only have
50 images opened up here some of you
guys thought it was a lot but then we
have commenters that actually work with
photos like i used to all the time
saying they never have only 50 open
there's a photographer that does some
great in-depth testing on macs and his
test has a thousand photos so i think
that r50 it's very reasonable and now
see if we have any differences in export
time between these all right wow the
first thing that i noticed is that our
cpu and gpu are being almost maxed out
on our 16 gig model but then looking at
the base one our gp is only at 66
percent and the cpu just above 20. now
if you're wondering why that is well
it's because the cpu and graphics can't
work any faster because they're limited
by their ram and more specifically the
swap of the ssds being so slow now
another interesting thing is that both
of these are using swap so if you buy
the 16 gig model you're not going to get
away from that it's using 3.25 compared
to about 6.9 on the 8 gig model alright
so that 16 gig one just got done
i have a minute and 11 seconds here it
might have been done before that maybe
angelica will put up the score right
here she'll check the camera
while our 8 gig model here
i mean how far has it gotten here it
doesn't even look like 25
yet and keep in mind we are not using
chrome or 10 tabs we are using safari
with only five tabs here's our video
there it's kind of glitching up
the whole system's kind of glitching up
here let me try scrolling
we're getting some delays check out
google drive same thing
that is pretty crazy this is what we're
talking about when we say this ssd issue
it's a real world issue it's not just
benchmarks if you're trying to destroy
the system that's not the case we're
exporting 50 images
and literally having five safari tabs
open here just out of curiosity i'm
going to go ahead and export that again
it's been three and a half minutes so
far and i just want to see what the
responsiveness will be like when we're
exporting now of course with this one we
are waiting way longer
and even to open up lightroom again i
clicked and i was like five six seconds
so while you're waiting you probably
want to use them on your machine but you
guys saw how much stuttering we're
getting i click and it only opens
many seconds later
all right
and then even switching tabs
they're getting reloaded this is not a
2022 experience now with this one let's
see what our multitasking is like
look at that
nothing has to get reloaded
everything is really quick no issues at
all and then of course it did that task
in just over one minute so the base
model took us eight minutes and 27
seconds
nearly eight times as long using safari
with five web browsing tabs that is
crazy now in our previous comparison
with the m1s we actually went up to 25
tabs in multiple apps before we saw big
slow downs so we basically know that the
base model is not for any type of
productivity if you also multitask now
just running this test without anything
else open other than lightroom it took
two minutes and 25 seconds so either way
the 16gb 512 is twice as fast even if
you have all the stuff opened up in the
background with web browsing
multitasking that's how much of a
difference it is now the base model is
still good if you're just web browsing
email whatever and you have the cash to
spend but if you care about productivity
i mean it is a huge letdown now as far
as coding we had people comment and say
what five web browsing tabs 10 webinars
and tabs i have 30 40 open i have all
this code open different github stuff so
let's go ahead and open up some more
tabs so i have five more opened up here
in chrome nothing crazy and now we are
compiling our code with our script xcode
is not using much ram at all but we're
still getting swap even on the 16 gig
model which proves that mac os will use
swap even if it doesn't have to because
we have extra ram available so that took
two minutes compared to two minutes and
12 seconds so not much of a difference
in terms of the configs for coding now
what about video editing well if you're
using final cut you're doing simple 4k
short projects with no other
productivity apps open there is very
little difference as long as you're not
touching the computer during your export
but if you start working on some tougher
projects or longer projects then you
start to notice a difference and of
course if you're multitasking
while you're exporting you're doing that
in the background you want to use your
computer that is where stuff starts to
glitch out our five minute prores
project took 7 minutes and 14 seconds to
export compared to
one minute and 52 seconds completely
negating the benefit of those prores
decoders and encoders built into the m2
chip and then if you're somebody like us
and when you're rendering a video you're
multitasking you're working on
thumbnails we have photoshop open our 16
gig opened up the image pretty much
instantly compared to taking 9 seconds
on the 8 gig model photoshop's glitching
up and now
our export just failed in final cut the
16 gig model has no issues instantly
opening up these different photos for
our hdr test that we run
super smooth we can go back into final
cut i keep running this export because
it literally does it so quickly the
system is extremely responsive we can go
ahead and open up all these tabs that
are in the background instantly no
issues let's go into safari here wow
super snappy while we're exporting that
on the base model my cursor is freezing
up
let's open up our web browser that was
about six seconds to open up each one
this is
crazy let's go into come on doc
open up we're getting beach balls
let's open up photoshop here
should i change these photos one one
thousand two one thousand three one
thousand four
five
six
okay
that was eight seconds i mean you guys
get the point here hope that second
export failed again because we were
trying to multitask so you really just
have to leave it and merging hdr files
in photoshop man this is unbearably slow
we it took literally 40 seconds on the
16 gig model while we're rendering and
here we're already over three minutes
and we are still waiting on this system
that is a real world slowdown
and honestly i have to say
that i would not wish
this configuration
on my enemy that does productivity in
that multitasks now with that said we
have to have a reasonable
mind even though you guys saw this this
is real world we're not pushing it
insanely we're seeing such slowdowns
not everybody is going to do this this
is the macbook air and although people
do coding on there some people play some
simple games some people do video
editing i think this higher end model is
going to be great for video editing um
not everybody's going to do that some
people are literally just going to web
browse
uh maybe google drive some very simple
stuff slack just communication and for
them the base model will do a decent job
now i still would say if you can afford
spending the extra 200 bucks to get the
512 do so you're gonna have this laptop
for a long time and for anybody else who
does multitask it does do even
occasional
hobby level productivity please
get yourself at least the 512 gigabyte
model some of you guys have asked well
if i can only choose one 16 gig or 512
which one would you do i would say do
the 512 because one you're getting
double the storage space that's going to
help out a lot
and two even the base m1 macbook air
that had the two nands uh the faster ssd
compared to this release
with the base model it did a great job
way better than this is doing so a lot
of the slow ssd issues will be fixed
with that 512 even if you can't get 16
gigs of ram so that would be my priority
all right it looks like this one is
almost done here bam
all right guys that was seven minutes
and 40 seconds in order to do that
compared to 40 seconds you guys let me
know your thoughts on this
what are your opinions once again
comment below if you guys want to win an
m2 macbook air and with that check out
one of those great videos right over
there click above to subscribe to help
us reach our goal of a million
subscribers this is max and i'll see you
in the next video
[Music]